und an furchtbare schreibens wasser und
zwar von den menschen die in dem schiff
war die im moment wohl das schiff sich
drehte und unterging war das ein
riesenschritt meilenweit zu hören war
von den menschen dort an bord
da habe ich immer noch hin
[Musik]
wegen dieser 30 januar in los so weit
ist noch erinnern können also der 30er
jahre begann damit dass wir aus lauf
termin hatten
denn unsere einheit wurde ja verlegt und
ich war ein angehöriger dieser einheit
und war also auf der gustloff und
zufälligerweise natürlich an meinem
geburtstag ja tagsüber liegt alles noch
sehr aufgeregt und und alles mögliche
aber zum abend bin ich dann zur ruhe
gekommen und habe gedacht du hast heute
geburtstag und muss zumindest mal den
kuchen in deiner oma die in geschickt
hat mal ausprobieren und auch mal ein
bisschen ein klein bisschen festlich
gestalten ganz gut zu fragen dazu
die sind auf diesem schiff tausend
menschen um sie herum wie macht sich der
soldat schönes tage möglich gar nicht
gar nicht dieses tausend menschen um
mich herum ist der eine dermaßen große
enge die herrschte ja nicht nur zwischen
den flüchtlingen die lagen fast
übereinander sogar in den gängen nachher
schon und ich war in meiner kohle und
froh und habe oben gesessen und war froh
dass ich erst mal irgendwo war wohl
nicht die kleine turbulenz herstellen
und dass das war denn meine
geburtstagsfeier einstimmung auf den
chefs stimmung die stimmung war also man
kann sich schlecht beschreiben ist jetzt
chef hat natürlich gearbeitet und man
hörte maschinen und was weiß ich alles
aber die stimmung die menschen waren
ruhig also es war keine aufgeregte
stimmung auf dem schiff denn jeder war
ja erst mal froh dass er seine seine
ecke gewonnen hatte wo er sich
niederlassen konnte wunsch und die um
die reise nun anzutreten also da war
keine turbulenz irgendwie die turbulenz
kam nach der tradierung und die kam so
stark dass es dann so weit kam dass
sogar die menschen sich gegenseitig
getreten und sogar totgetreten haben auf
den gängen
um nach draußen zu kommen jetzt sehen
sie den den moment wie sie dinge erlebt
haben als sie ja es hat drei mal rutscht
aber richtig so dass du so dass du aus
deinen sitzt richtig hoch gedrückt wurde
und zweimal und der triste kam etwas
später da war dann im maschinen und
haben die anderen beiden kantonen
vorschriften und das vorschiff ist auch
von anfang an den sehr stark abgesagt
das geht anderen kommt ja was geht einem
durch den kopf
ich will ihn was sagen ob das nur mir so
geht weiß ich nicht aber im moment der
geschehnisse registrierst du nur was im
moment passiert du überlegst nicht was
drum herum sein könnte was er werden die
folgen sein können oder auch nicht
sondern zunächst erstmal registrierst du
das jetzt etwas passiert und jetzt muss
zusehen wie du fertig bist mit den
dingen die da jetzt ablaufen so da bin
ich natürlich denn raus aus manacor
versucht und da bin ich dann als lade
gekommen das war der schule eine etage
höher und
da habe ich gesehen dass das vorschiff
also schon unter wasser sein muss sie
denn im laden dick war schon wasser so
und ich bin dann rechts war soll die
schmale tür zu diesen gang nach oben
führt wusste ich ja weil ich vorher auf
dem schiff für mich informiert hatte ich
war beauftragt die die geräte unseren
landvolk stelle an bord zu bringen
die sollten also mit transportiert
werden bei der verlegung und das
versteht fing tage vorher schon an und
gleich neugieriger mensch von natur aus
so ein bisschen bin habe ich mich
natürlich immer wenn ich an bord war
mich auch mal umgesehen und dadurch bin
ich da ein bisschen kundig gewesen dass
ich wusste wie stahl links geht und das
ist eben ein dadurch bin ich den ganzen
trubel den tief die die flüchtlinge ja
nun erzeugt haben auch keiner wusste die
sind waren alle auf ihre plätze gegangen
und keiner wusste jetzt eigentlich
richtig um im ernstfall muss ich hinauf
oder runter wo ist der abstieg wo geht's
hin oder welchen gang musik gehen da bin
ich dort und dort hinkommen hat ja
keiner gewusst und dadurch war eine eine
unheimliche eine unheimlich unheimliches
durcheinander entstanden
und das hat letztendlich ja sogar nach
hier dann auch und menschliche züge
angenommen dass man sie sehen das also
was habe ich gesehen wie gesagt ich war
ja auf dem sonnendeck oben und habe mich
da denn aufgehalten die ganze zeit aber
ich habe gesehen dass ein offizier seine
frau und seine kinder erschossen hat und
sich selbst auch solche sachen sind dort
vorgekommen
und da ist das doch das ist das break
doch wenn du sowas siehst
das waren eigentlich wenig so will meine
an sitzende kriegserlebnisse die ich
gehabt habe ansonsten war ich funker an
land und hatte auf deutsche sachen einen
schönen job gemacht ich hab funksprüche
wiederholen müssen auf der das ist max
egger dollar war das der punkt der
aufnahme von der
und ich habe dann immer die funksprüche
die an die u-boote adressiert waren habe
ich auch lange auf lengsfeld wiederholt
längst wäre es eine ausbreitung die die
also nicht in die atmosphäre geht wie
die kurzwelle sondern die sich an die
sich in bodennähe ausbreitet so dass die
u-boote die getaucht waren und der noch
mal hoch kam mit ihren anti raus aus dem
wasser raus war
diese frucht sprüche empfangen konnten
es also diesen moment realisiert haben
dass sie geschossen worden sind nein
nein nein gar nichts ich gar nicht ich
bin so mit meiner hose ich kann dir eine
blaue hose und werden diese diesem blatt
ist rollkragenpullover der üblich vor
bei der marine
den hatte ich an und weiter nicht aber
bei den ganzen utensilien mein seesack
da war ja alles sehen was zu mir gehört
der ist also dort wo er stand auch
mitziehen untergegangen auf den gängen
wahrscheinlich unglaubliche panik ja ja
ja ja ja zunächst erst mal war es alles
sehr unruhig die menschen haben haben
sich gegenseitig was zugerufen und und
und und also ein bisschen panik war
durch sturm und jeder machte nach seinem
temperament sich als eine panik selbst
also sonst so eine leichte panik war ja
bei mir auch und ich habe dann erst mal
versucht was machst du jetzt ist die
umgebung viel wie kannst du am besten
hier zurecht kommen und dann bin ich ab
denn jeder angekommen versucht man erst
nach oben und da wusste ich dass dieser
standort hoch ging von dem für die
maschine ist um sich darum dass luft
schnappen
dadurch bin ich nach oben und ich war
heilfroh dass ich nachher oben war
erstmal
und wie ging es weiter das schiff also
es knallt und plötzlich auf dem schiff
so richtig so merkt dass das ganze
schiff vibriert und zwar war dass der
vorgang für die schotten gebrochen sind
das schiff hatte 44 abgeschüttelt also
vier schotten denn die sicherheits
schotten und die haben noch gehalten
aber durch diese übermäßige belastung
des schiffes sind die dann gebrochen und
dann hat die mächtigen krach gegeben
und dann fängt das schiff an natürlich
sich noch bei der migration geht die
wassermenge tragen denn überall ein wo
sie bisher noch nicht waren und haben
das schiff natürlich mächtig
stabilisiert so und das führte dazu dass
es das schon die die die wirken noch
schon schon ins wasser eintaucht und da
habe ich das musste verschwinden und
dann bin ich rüber auf die andere seite
benannt will bin an steuerbord passport
waren die treffer bin ich an steuerbord
wir in den runden tisch ins wasser rein
so und es ist zu bedenken
es war der 30 januar windstärke 7
einige eisschollen schwamm auf dem
wasser
also es war sehr kalt und jemand der
keinen stabilen kreislauf hatte ist
sicher bei dem eintauchen in diese kalte
wasser schon hat dann nicht nein sagen
hat das nicht überlebt so und ich bin
hab' dann auch noch das vielleicht schon
zehn minuten nur der finsternis dauerte
nicht lange da hat man ein bisschen
slams in ein rettungsboot eingezogen
so glaube ich vorne managen sportcast
nun abgeben
habt ihr auch zeitweise mal gerudert
denn ich war ja auch nass und habe
mein körper bisschen in gang zu halten
und habe dann einfach mit mit gerudert
ist ja ja das war ja das war der letzte
ausweg ganz eindeutig das geht hier
automatisch geht also jetzt ist letzte
point jetzt muss zusehen wie die klage
jetzt ist jetzt alles vorbei
irgend welche handlungsmöglichkeiten
nicht mehr geben jetzt musst du
irgendwas machen haben sie zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch irgendetwas von ihrer
umgebung bekommen nein nein sicher wo ja
aber es ist mir nicht erinnerlich
das sind das sind das jetzt zum momente
wo du wo du irgendwo wo du nur
fokussiert bis auf deine eigenen
sicherheit an deine eigene rettung und
alles andere interessiert nicht mehr
nein nein
die einzelnen gedanken sind was machst
du jetzt andere klassen hast du nicht du
denkst du angst hat man ja auch angst
glaube ich habe ich angst gehabt ich
weiß es nicht die kommt hinterher
ich habe auch den eindruck
dadurch dass ein junger mensch war ich
war 19 jahre alt und die ganze dramatik
des geschehens kommt erst später wenn du
älter bist dann kommt ihr mit kommt ihr
das alles erst zu bewusstsein
ich glaube in als junger mensch und dass
es geht wohl auch vielen soldaten die im
krieg waren
irgend etwas dramatisches wird als
augenblick erlebnis registriert aber
weil er nicht
ja
die ganzen tausenden menschen um sie
herum
ja ich war ja dann nachher im
rettungsboot
loewe hatte uns dann im schlepp dann
plötzlich wurde mir wieder geklappt weil
sie in u boot bekämpfung machten das war
ja wohl noch da irgendwo in der nähe und
das haben sich wohl registriert und dann
haben sich noch ein paar wasserbomben
geworfen das heißt eine zeit lang haben
wir herrn geschwommen ohne und also dort
auf dem wasser und wurde dann im
nachhinein nachher wieder in deutschland
doch noch geholt
zu der zeit als sie im letzteres boot
saß
das u-boot verfolgt hat weiß denn die
kunst los
ja und zwar hatte uns ja und er wir
haben getrieben ja und ich habe ja die
gustloff gesehen also doch schon eine
ganzen ganz entfernt nicht nicht so die
wir waren nicht dicht sagen also das
waren doch schon sagen wir eine seemeile
vielleicht waren wir doch schon ab das
sind wir dann sehen wir sind 1,8
kilometer ungefähr so also waren wir
doch schon geschrieben und da habe ich
die wurst läuft noch gesehen und dann
wie die uhr unter ging hat sie sich noch
mal irgendwie aufgerichtet das sah so
aus als wenn sie sich einmal ganz in
ihre längsachse gedreht hat aber das war
aber nicht erfahren und an furchtbare
freischalten übrigens wasser und zwar
von den menschen die in dem schiff waren
die im moment wohl das schiff sich
drehte und unterging war das einlesen
schneider weit meilenweit zu hören war
von den menschen dort an bord
den steuer habe ich immer noch hin
und dann bord sagten sie waren bei mir
nicht nur soldaten sondern waren frauen
ja also dieses schiff war ja eigentlich
die ganze aktion das hier verhandelt den
auftakt gibt zwei coups limbus lea
division nach kiel zu bringen und dann
wurde da ja die flüchtlingsfrage akut
wurde durch die brötchen vormarsch der
roten armee wurde dann von von der von
der von der leitung von der stabs
leitung festgelegt dass also nicht dass
das schiff freie kapazitäten da sind auf
jeden fall frauen und kinder mitzunehmen
sind und der erste befehl lautete mütter
mit kindern aufzunehmen und das ist auch
geschehen
aber im nachhinein nachher kurz vor dem
auslaufen sind hier dann ist ja jeder
der da war also wir hatten auch mehr
frauen kinder alles also es war fast
eine panikattacke von diesen menschen um
nur noch auf dem schiff zu kommen auch
so ähnlich kann ich mir prozent haben
diese menschen auch gefühlt das ist ja
das letzte was sie fast jeden kann auf
das schiff damit gaddafi weg noch einmal
aufleuchtete oder ist ja ja ja zu anfang
zu anfang war war durch den durch die
maschine war ja die maschine war ja
schon dann bald überflutet und da waren
die ganzen aggregate waren liegen ja
nicht mehr und du hattest kein licht und
im untergang ist das schiff tatsächlich
dann hat sich noch einmal aufgerichtet
und jetzt ja mit der nase zuerst unter
wasser voll beleuchtet voll beleuchtet
so was wenn du als während er im hafen
dahin also seine seine präferenzen hat
so so ist der chef er ist besessen sie
in diesem zelt ums brot ja
ja die haben mich dann haben uns ja
immer einer nach dem anderen hochgezogen
also zweiter mann haben denn da
gestanden und haben versucht er die
menschen da draußen und ob die löwen das
war ein torpedo wurde ein norwegisches
fall war während der zeit wie wir
norwegen waren hat man das requirieren
und dann wurde dass sie nur aus sehr
eingesetzt da gab es noch zwei handelt
drei handel glaube ich noch die auch
norwegischen ursprungs waren wenn sie
erinnerungen an einzelne personen in dem
moment wo sie da suchte dann gleich ein
kind den sie für den kontakt hatten oder
warum irgendjemand speziell ist ja ein
so genanntes apple 7 10
das war ein bayer er spielt jetzt so gut
also gitarre und hat auch mal schön
gesungen und wie ich an bord wie sie
mich rausholen und ich danach da sah ich
dass apple sich warm auch und wollte
hoch greifen wollte noch sich noch
irgendwo festhalten und sagte dann ab
war weg also form der ist vor meine
augen regelrecht unterging
also dann irrtum dass man so will sind
sie da weiß ich doch ein soldat einmal
wieder einmal die nicht von also kollege
von mir von der funke von der funke
rainer funke ja
denken wenn man diese linie retten
können denn das glaube ich nicht denn er
war er war so sah man noch einen halben
meter vom boot ab und machte so die
letzten schwimmversuche und wollen sie
dann sich noch irgendwo festhalten
aber das hat nicht mehr gereicht seither
unter wasser abpumpen schon weg war
das war so meinen das war also mein
dramatisches mit ein bisschen
dramatisches kriegsereignisse ansonsten
war ich ja keiner front wohl irgendwie
lassen hab da irgendwo geschossen oder
gemacht das war ja alles nicht herbei
sofern begünstigt ja ich war ja in der
ausbildung als funker und den kunden
haben wurde ein wurde ein an ein test
gemacht mit uns und zwar dieser tests
erst mal mussten wir tauchen mit dem
tauchen retter arbeiten da musste da war
so ein riesengroßer tang mit wasser da
musstest du denn diese diese tauch
versuche dieses diese rettungsversuche
nachmachen und mit dem tauchen er da und
dann wurde wurde wollen wir geprüft ob
wir wie nennt man das ob man sicher ist
weil bei besonderen dramatischen
ereignissen hat man da psychologischen
das jubeljahr psychologische belastung
so so ein test wurde mit mir auch
gemacht und man hat mich also nicht
genommen auf ein verbot außerdem war ich
kenne von beruf war also kein kein
technischer ich habe keinen technischen
beruf das hat vielleicht auch etwas dazu
beigetragen dass man mich an land
eingesetzt hatte obgleich sie jede menge
leute brauchen für einen franc rode
da war die und die unter ganz cooney
wohliger immer größer letzten phase des
krieges und sie sucht ja dringend leute
aber sie haben mich dann aussortiert
ich war also nicht hat das suchen sich
habe wie man sagt irgendwie nein gar
nicht
ich glaube jeder soldat hat auch
versucht während der kriegsjahre 1 ist
es ein bisschen auch für sich ein
bisschen was was ihm persönlich gut tut
zu zu unternehmen und und und das war in
diesem fall haben sagt jetzt bist du
erst mal aus dem größten es bisher hier
sitzt der erst mal hoch und trocken wie
man früher sagte und jaja das gerade
anfang des krieges unglaubliche
begeisterung fliegen musste günther
kretzschmar ja ja ja ja so die stimmung
immer waren krank die begeisterung war
nicht mehr da also vom begeistern konnte
man nicht mehr sprechen absolut nicht
mehr denn die jeder wusste um die
ereignisse um die burg vorteile jeder
wusste dass da jeden tag immer irgendwo
im boot up apotheken untergeht und viele
kameraden der auch ihr leben lassen also
das war doch schon eine bedrückte
stimmung also von von irgendwie von hier
mit mit hallo und jetzt geht's los und
so war ist da nicht nicht mehr
wahnsinnig zu bekommen sind sie
eingezogen worden oder haben sie sich
frei ich habe mich freiwillig gemeldet
zur marine
weil weil bei uns in der schule die ss
abgeworben hat und so ssv absolut nicht
und da ich ja am wasser gewohnt habe
mein leben und als junger mensch auch
viel gesegelt umgebracht haben
unsere großeltern ein haus abwasser hat
am see am lankower see war ich doch so
ein bisschen wasser gezogen und hat mich
gedacht aus diesem dilemma konstituieren
auswendig freiwillig meldet ist und das
war dann natürlich die marine weil ich
mit
ja sowieso ein bisschen sympathisiert
habe ja gehen auf die zeit nach der
rettung wie ging es dann weiter
und das haben sie dann werden die nasse
kleidung vom leib geschnitten und uns
dann in die maschine in den
maschinenraum verfrachtet wo es warm war
mit was schneidet man kleidung vom leib
messer die leute haben alle messer und
was kriegen tonnen an
also zunächst erst mal kriegst du gar
nichts ändern und bei bleiben haben
spiele der nacht unten im maschinen
haben gelegen und dann kam natürlich die
besatzung und haben vor allem für die
frauen erstmal decken gebracht und die
bisschen schnee liegt ein fasste
auftauchte zuerst mal das bisschen im
groben erstmal bis hinab zu ändern so
und dann habe irgendjemand hat mir dann
auch noch ein colani gegeben und was
weis ich jedenfalls wie wir an land
gebracht wurden hat man uns völlig neu
eingekleidet wir hatten ja nicht keine
unter der schicken kein oberfläche nicht
also wir waren eigentlich im prinzip
waren wir die nachricht nicht und haben
dann also alles was so irgendwie
bisschen bisschen anschlussfähig oder
irgendwie war haben wir versucht erstmal
über zwei jahren
und dann sind wir in kolberg in eine
kaserne in eine schule gekommen und in
dieser schule wollen wir dann mit mit
uniformen teilen aus erstmal bekleidet
das heißt ich hatte eine rose von der
luftwaffe und unfall an die von der
marine und und und und von sonstwo also
du warst also das war keine kleine
einheitliche kleidung sondern das war zu
sagen gesucht ist krank zusammengesucht
die kleidung und die uns dann da erst
mal weg und dann bin ich von von von
dort aus mit dem boot nach sassnitz
gekommen und in sassnitz bin ich sind
wir dann richtig wieder ausgerüstet
worden mit allem was
so brauchten und er werde sie angehört
in dem moment wo sie aus dem wasser
gezogen dann ist da noch irgendwie so
dieses register totales chaos
wahrscheinlich ist ein bewusst oder aus
dem rettungsprogramm sind jetzt jetzt
habe ich überlebt jetzt ja natürlich
man hatte das gefühl aber mit bewusst
also so bewusst dass ich sage ja das
registrierst du eigentlich erst mal
richtig im nachhinein was ist da
passiert was haben die damals gemacht
und wie war das sind und so also denn
jetzt haben wir der moment wie es
passiert der läuft bei dir nur
schematisch ab den regisseur ist jetzt
rege zu wirst du dich als drama als
irgendwas das ist das ist alles so im
moment das ist im moment wie man so sagt
der mensch greift nach dem strohhalm
und das ist erst mal der seine rettung
da geht nicht hier oben im gehirn wer
weiß was da vor sich 100 und konnte gott
und was wissen wollen
das kommt alles bilder von sitze
entfielen danach sind wir dann nach nach
mit der bahn nach kiel gekommen
kiel weg da war da war dass die u-bahn
die übungseinheiten in kiel wik so und
in kiel wie konnte man mich nicht
gebrauchen dann hat man mich
abkommandiert nachzählen das ist ein
durchgangslager an einem riesen lager
gewesen da waren alle möglichen leute
zusammen gesammelt die aus irgendwelchen
gründen nicht nicht besondere
einsatzbefehle hatten die an um nach um
nach berlin zu gehen und berlin zu
verteidigen
der große gefehlt von töne zum führer
befehlen was weiß ich wie sich das
damals so nannte alles auf berlin
verteidigen und da ich ja
so also safe ungar war konnte ich mit
der land vorgereiht die man mir
angedacht hatte an land ja nichts
anfangen
das war ja völlig was anderes so wollte
mit tornister gelitten und hauptsächlich
sprechen und so weiter all diese dinge
die hatten wir die wir haben ja mit
taste gearbeitet an bord von einer
ausbildungsstätte nach der zur anderen
wollen wir denn immer getrieben durch
die oder medien aufrückte und uns immer
wieder vertrieben hat von den
ausbildungsstätten und jetzt ging immer
weiter westwärts und so landete ich dann
nachher in den tag hinein und so den
nach crivitz und das ist daher in der
nähe von meinem heimatort gewesen und
habe bin ich eben bin ich eben in
schweden gelandet
[Musik]
also ja es gab zu der zeit die so
genannten plattendeal ich diese bilder
die das waren einheiten die hatten hier
so ein großes schild vor der voller
brust und wir hatten gesagt jetzt helden
klar wie gesagt immer das hilton klaus
und damit wir diesen nicht in die ferne
kommen haben wir vom von von dem
kommando wir ab wir haben einen
entscheiden bekommen dass wir beauftragt
sind innerhalb von drei tagen die
ausbildung in crivitz zu beginnen so
dass hier also mussten wir sind auf
dienstreise sagt man und praktisch oder
auf kommando reise so dass dieser helden
klar uns da nicht noch abfangen konnte
und der besagte drei tage so und für
ihren tag ihm habe ich durch zufall
stand ein lkw mit dem anhänger ich sage
dir hin wir fahren nach schwerin
so sah ich das kann ich nicht mitfahren
denn ich hatte mir gedacht ich will
ihnen das wird ein bisschen unter bis zu
wählen
diesmal einfach zu hause während von
schwerin nach crivitz kommst du immer
noch wieder ein bisschen näher hat der
drei tage da schaffte das christin so
und da sachen ja du kannst mitfahren
aber wir machen dich darauf aufmerksam
wie haben munition hinten drauf
während die in die luft gestemmt kommst
du dich nach schwerin
so aber es ist nichts passiert wird sind
entschuldigen gelandet von morgens um 4
zu hause habe meine oma es gibt stimmen
die sagen ja entschuldigen werde porsche
hin
die hat er mich noch gar nicht mal so
und naja und mittags um zwölf war der
amerikaner mit seinen panzern am
pfaffenteich in schwerin
damit war für mich der krieg beendet
welcher tag war beim 5
nein ich bin hier aufgewachsen bei den
großeltern zunächst erst nicht habe
danach jedoch aber sie hat mir eine eine
sache erzählt sie war bei hat am
fernseher gesessen und hat gestrickt und
dann hat es hinter ihr gepoltert und er
hat sie gedacht da ist eine blume
runtergefahren kommt von vorn von links
ob ständer aber war nicht da hat sie
gesagt hat diese gedacht hier ist
irgendetwas passiert entweder dem dem
dem horst oder oder beim oder dem den in
dem sohn von den schönen aber das war ja
und das war am 30 januar
das war an meinem interesse der beiden
geburtstag hat sie dieses empfinden
gehabt sagt sie was dann muss ich die rc
und sagt sie das ist
ich habe mich gewundert und glaubt
gedacht dass irgendwas bearbeite
irgendwas muss passiert sein
und jetzt höre ich von dir das zu
tatsächlich an dem tag untergehen
das ist schon ein fünfter sich in der 65
ich weiß es war so die reaktion von
ihrer oma debatte war sogar die war so
aufgeregt über die hat dass das fallen
die ganzen geschehnisse waren ja alle
sehr nachher aus schon und dann kam der
amerikaner ja und hatte und hat war ja
in schwerin das erzählt ich und er ist
ja auch in lankow gewesen und hat sich
die dieses haus angeguckt und meine oma
hat der händler gesagt bsh wie man so
sagt
da durch sagt joana du hast ja bei den
gleichen tag bei mama ja ja ja ich hätte
mich ja das war an den bäumen
angeschlagen ehemalige krise ehemalige
soldaten melden sich so haben sich zu
melden oder schiff kann man natur was
weiß ich wieder aufstand jaja
erschießung der erschießung weil nicht
bevor und erschießen
ja da hab ich gesagt du musst immer
ziemlich klein machen und das war mein
einziger aus recht wenig versucht habe
und ja auch geklappt hat und es sind ja
viele auf dem ort habe ich gehört die
sind alle noch nachher in englische
gefangenschaft gegangen sie sind also
noch ein zwei jahre doch tatsächlich
noch noch dann mitgenommen worden und
waren nicht zu hause
wie sind sie dieser riet gefangenschaft
entkommen dieser ist ein weiteres ja
zunächst erst mal war für mich der krieg
aus aber wie gesagt es waren diese
drohbriefe an den bäumen plan
und da habe ich gedacht was machst du
nur
dann habe ich mir kurze hosen angezogen
und habe mich mit den kindern mit den
kindern zusammen getan werden sie
spielten dann habe ich damit gemacht das
war zügig für mich erst mal meinen
selbst ausgesucht der freiwillig den ich
mir das schuf und es hat auch niemand
nachher nachher irgendwie gefragt oder
gemacht und getragen wird
die sache ist im sande verlaufen da ist
sagten die nicht nachgekommen
nein nein ich bin da wirklich
ich habe wie soll ich sagen ich habe
viel glück gehabt dass ich da nicht
nicht in die fänge da irgendwelche
irgendwelche menschen gekommen wenn die
da in beauftragt waren irgendwas laut zu
machen
für mich muss ich sagen da bin ich ganz
gut durchgekommen und haben im moment so
richtig realisiert dass jetzt die
kiefern 1 1 1
schon der ganze ablauf aber laufen nach
dem unglück nach dem gold-wurf unglück
da merkte man also jetzt geht es langsam
alles eine eine eine nummer weiter
runden die ganzen abläufe auch und und
und auch von daten bei uns im mm wir
irgendwann unser haus ist zu einem ring
ist es ist das erinnern wir dass eine
gaststätte und da ist eine straße drum
rum und auf der anderen seite sind die
häuser so angeordnet und in dieser
straße standen jede menge militär autos
lkws privatarmee also alles was zur
armee gehörte wurde dort abgestellt und
die soldaten sind denn auch irgendeine
art und weise irgendwo verschwunden
und wo anderen weg koffer mit geld und
großen sack mit mit zucker und und
unwort 20 haben wir denn da erstmal hier
haben wir dann die zocker haben wir denn
aufgeteilt in der cloud auf der straße
wieder hatte ich einen großen beutel mit
zucker holen können solche sachen haben
wir gemacht also wir haben diese diese
fahrzeuge denn auch so klein bisschen
kleingeld gibt geplündert muss ich sagen
das was wir gebrauchen konnten haben wir
rausgeholt
hatten sie schon davor damit gerechnet
als sie haben ja ließen diesen
dienstreise und sie sagt ihr sie wollen
immer weiter nach westen geschickt war
das schon da so im hinterkopf das moor
ist okay die west frauen kommt auch
weiter das einzige der so darauf gehofft
und dann kann sich bis dahin ein das hat
mich mehr überrascht also gehofft habe
ich so was nicht mehr also als soldat
denkst du nicht da wirst du kommentiert
auf deutsch gesagt das war so usus lange
denken es wird war nicht angesagt
sondern bewusst papier wurde befohlen
und das handelst du zu machen und dann
war die sache erledigt so und irgendwie
unter diesem aspekt bisher denn
jahrelang dann auch erzogen
ja ich habe in meinen 94 jahren doch
möglich sagen einiges erlebt ja einiges
erlebt
allerdings bin ich ein mensch der alles
sehr gelassen nimmt
sie haben ja 2014/15 auch in dieser
zeitung und übertragen chance bekommen
in diese debatte über die flüchtlinge
hochgekocht ist in deutschland und sie
haben ja selbst mitbekommen wie die
flugbewegungen im zweiten weltkrieg war
sie an selbst 1000 flüchtlinge mit an
bord der gustloff wie fühlt sich das an
was denken sie
wenn sie wenn sie jetzt diese beiden
lebensereignisse miteinander vergleichen
welche gedanken kommen hinter da muss
ich sagen dass wir uns mächtig mächtig
daneben benehmen
insofern das nehmen wir als beispiel die
unsere ostpreußen flüchtlinge ins
mecklenburgische oder sagen wir mal in
den westen damals kam und der krieg
hatte ja auch es gab ja kaum was zu
essen und die menschen haben ja wirklich
auch teilweise warum hat und so weiter
und da war die solidarität der deutschen
untereinander nicht beispielhaft bis hin
zu unmöglich so und wer nicht in
parallele zu heute mit den flüchtlingen
aus welchen gründen sie auch immer
hierherkommen nicht das thema
unterschiedlich sein aber sie sind nun
mal hier und es sind menschen das sind
menschen und den gegenüber ist man
zumindest solidarisch müsste man sein
gegenüber und das möglichste machen
versuchen dass der halbwegs dass die
halbwegs auch aus ihrer misere
herauskommen denn die stecken ja auch in
einer mini also die was ich den
klimawandel den herzigen weitaus
dramatischer ein als das was ich
mitgemacht habe ehrlich gedacht denn es
gibt ja nach wegen das man nur die die
weltmeere dass sie dich um und haben
wieder erhöhen
was meinen sie was dann passiert wie
vielen menschen hunderte oder tausende
ihr obdach verlieren und die kommen dann
hier zu uns als flüchtlinge und werden
dann so behandelt wie die flüchtlinge
die wir jetzt hier bei herrn das gibt
wächst aus zu einer dramatik davor habe
ich angst
[Musik]
das ist kein schönes aber ein starkes
schluss war da
ja ja ja ja ich bin ja ein bisschen
optimistischer